[Music]
back in the late 90s we introduced the
baloney detection kit inspired by Carl
Sagan's demon-haunted world where he had
a chapter on the baloney detection kid
he had his set of questions I kind of
developed my own because I started
encountering other people that disagreed
with me you know we never went to the
moon people conspiracy people whatever
and I thought okay so how do we know if
I don't know what's coming down the pike
saying ten years from now if I was gonna
teach my students how to think
critically what what are the key points
like this basic questions they could ask
so it begins with one you know how
reliable is the source of the claim you
know here's the claim how reliable is it
what's the evidence for it what's the
quality of the evidence where where does
it come from
who said that you know is this some you
know fake news alternative site thing or
is it you know the Wall Street Journal
or the New York Times I mean the source
really matters has anyone tried to
disprove the claim you know this is
super important because everybody thinks
they're right and every website has
testimonials about this product or that
idea the question is not what do your
supporters think but what's do the
people who don't agree with you think
because that's what I want to know does
anyone run an experiment to try to
disprove your theory you know and so in
science this is as basically as it gets
Karl Popper called this the principle of
falsification that is we can't ever
prove a theory correct but we can
disprove it by having an experiment that
shows it's wrong okay so if you can't
falsify it you know what are you really
doing and my favorite story on this by
the way let me just have a little
sidetrack here from from Carl he's got
this great little section in his book
demon haunted world there's a dragon in
my garage okay I have a dragon in my
garage you want to see it come here let
me show you so I pull up the garage door
I go look can you see the dragon and you
look in there you know I don't see
anything oh sorry this is an invisible
dragon an invisible dragon yeah yeah
yeah he's invisible
well what if we put some flour on the
ground and then we'll get the footprints
of the dragon well no see this is a
special dragon that hovers above the
ground it floats it's an invisible
floating dragon
an invisible floating drag okay oh wait
I have some infrared cameras here we can
detect the heat from the dragon now see
this is a cold-blooded dragon it doesn't
give off any heat what about the fire we
can detect the fire that the dragon
spits up no it spits out cold fire okay
you see the problem if there's no way
for me to falsify that there's a dragon
there what's the difference between an
invisible floating heatless dragon and
no dragon at all none and of course we
can apply this to God or any other
supernatural paranormal type but not if
I can't debunk it if I can't falsify it
if there's no way to test it that how
will we ever know it's true this is the
core of the baloney detection kit we
have to be able to get to whether it's
true or not in some way so it's not just
my opinion versus your opinion and we
shattered each other then we want to
know is does the claim it's personal
belief somehow enter in because of
course we all have personal opinions and
beliefs about things my politics my
religion my ideology can influence me it
doesn't make it wrong but it's good to
know if somebody has an agenda you know
so when you watch Fox News you know that
they have an agenda for sure or there's
other sources on the left that have a
liberal agenda maybe NPR who knows but
you see it's good to know that just in
case so when you hear the faggio well
maybe but I know this guy has an agenda
so you know that's the kind of thing
does the new idea being proposed account
for the same amount of information that
the old idea does and some of the new
anomalies that the old idea can't
explain so people offer theories also
called alternative theories of physics
for example and they always send them to
me going hey listen you know I'm not
good at math but if you help me with the
math I'll share the Nobel Prize with you
right I don't do math and physics so you
know you might take it to the local high
school physics teacher before you
announce that you've made the greatest
discovery since Newton Einstein the
problem with that is the current
theories do pretty well at explaining
most everything not everything so
there's always anomalies we can't
explain so maybe there's new some new
theory coming down the pike that might
account for all the old theories
explanations and the new anomalies the
anomalies that
the old theory can't explain baby but
again we got to be able to test it first
and so those are the kinds of things
does the claim it play by the rules of
science that the rules of the field that
you're in for example again these
alternative physics guys come to me
don't come to me I'm not a physicist did
you at least ask the local high school
physics teacher if this makes any sense
because if you have no training you
don't know all the mistakes that people
in the past have already made to get to
where they are now and if you're
starting here without the background
you're gonna make lots of mistakes okay
so these are the sorts of things that
any good
baloney detector should know I call this
skepticism 101 it's the course I teach
it Chapman University these are incoming
freshmen it's a critical thinking course
but it's really just how to detect
baloney and not everything's baloney
some things turn out to be true like the
theory of evolution the theory the Big
Bang germ theory of disease plate
tectonics in geology these are things
that were once radically heretical and
now they're accepted how did that happen
it happened because they have evidence
and that's what you need
[Music]